cette semaine j'ai choisi de parler du
prolongement bien sûr du pass sanitaire
de la vote du vote pardon de la loi de
vigilance sanitaire avec une assemblée
vide à on parlait de l'abstention devant
les urnes on peut parler de
l'absentéisme parlementaire 75 voix aux
74 voix contre 73 qui font passer
finalement la possibilité d'avoir
recours au passé l'inter jusqu'en
juillet 2022 la loi qui passe à 135 voix
finalement pour dire qu'on est en état
d'urgence permanent cette loi de
vigilance sanitaire mois elle m'inquiète
au plus haut point depuis le début le
fait qu'elle soit encore allongée de
huit mois est encore plus inquiétant
parce que ça veut dire qu'on rentre dans
la société de la vigilance voulue par
macron à l'époque de du risque
terroriste mais attention on a juste le
risque terroriste le risque maintenant
du virus qu'elle risque on va ajouter
pour enfermer les gens dans une société
de la paranoïa totale du contrôle de
tous par tous je crois qu'il est temps
de dire stop et là encore voilà la
responsabilité des politiques qui ne se
déplace pas quand ils sont
parlementaires qui ne font pas
finalement un débat digne de ce nom par
rapport à une loi qui engagent notre
démocratie notre façon aussi de vivre en
société vers une société de la vie dans
ce que je refuse absolument vous savez
quoi vous allez finir par me convaincre
et le vote de cette loi va finir par me
convaincre moi si je trouve ça
scandaleux la manière dont ça a été voté
comme vous le dites avec très peu de
députés qu'ils soient déplacés alors que
ça aussi important que vous venez de le
dire et surtout voilà que le
gouvernement se donne sans autre forme
de procès la possibilité de perpétuer ce
se passe alors que pour l'instant la
situation sanitaire est
au meilleur de sa forme ce ferveur au
plus bas pour le nombre de cas
[Musique]